you know I just want to see a poster for
this movie that tells the absolute truth
it just says in big words from the
director of Max Payne a good day to die
hard or die hard five is directed by
John Moore Stars Bruce Willis and Jai
Courtney I am a huge fan of die hard I
like every single one of them yes
hardcore fans even four so if anyone was
excited for this movie it was me I love
these movies I've watched them countless
times I think there's so much fun
they're some of the best action movies
ever made they all contain great stunt
work one in three in particular are my
favorites die hard with a vengeance I
find extremely underrated I love die
hard big fan and this movie John McClane
is in Russia because his son has gotten
into trouble his son is a spy who's
trying to protect this political
prisoner of sorts the same time there's
an entire terrorist plot going on behind
the scenes that both of them aren't
entirely sure about yet and once father
and son clash together lots of
explosions and car crashes happen and we
have a die hard movie now I was excited
for this movie purely because it is a
die hard film and I really wanted this
movie to be good but I was concerned
about the director though because he
made behind enemy lines with Owen Wilson
and gene Hackman well at times an
entertaining movie probably one of the
most unrealistic war movies I've ever
seen and he also made the cinematic
disaster Max Payne which was just sad so
going to die hard five I was optimistic
walking out of die hard five I was
crying this movie sucks
I'm so sorry guys I'm so sorry to tell
you this if anyone was supposed to like
this movie it was me I loved all of the
other die hard movies I really was
sitting there during this movie just in
pain every single person I talked to
after the movie felt the exact same way
now hear me out cuz I know I just
disappointed you and I want to apologize
because I'm a fan like you guys I'm a
fan of this series and I really wanted
this movie to be good but honestly
nothing leading up to it made me think
it was going to be there's all these
really over-the-top CGI shots in the
trailer which by the way gives away all
of the big moments in this movie if you
saw the trailer you saw all the big
moments that's for sure so there are
certain things that a die-hard movie
needs and a die-hard fan of die hard
requires these certain things
be there which is why some people were
disappointed with diehard four because
it didn't have as much of the f words of
the cussing or anything or like really
bloody violence even though there was a
substantial amount of action in that
movie people were excited about this
movie because the rated R rating is back
that means more F words more blood I
gotta be honest with you 100% except for
a couple well-timed headshot with some
blood
diehard four is more violent in this
movie no joke except for a couple bloody
moments that's it and I know you want to
know is the catchphrase in there is a
complete yes it's in there that doesn't
mean it's a good movie how many times
did you say the f-word I'd say about
five or six times yeah so if you're
really excited for this big R movie
there's really nothing about it that
screams rated R no as I said there are
things that a fan requires to be in the
die hard movies number one John McClane
isms that means he's a foul-mouthed guy
who jokes when he should be worried for
his life he says stuff he laughs you'll
like him you dig the guy you want him to
survive do we have that in this movie to
an extent the character of John McClane
is not completely raped as the die hard
franchise is with this film the
character remains intact he's there he
pops a few one-liners he's entertaining
he's a likable guy you get that okay
number two on the list of things
required is a great villain Hans Gruber
from die hard fan tastic villain you got
to see him and John McClane go back and
forth with great dialogue terrific
performance by Alan Rickman die hard
three with Jeremy Irons another great
villain and you know I got to be honest
Timothy Olyphant and die hard for I
thought he did a great job in that movie
I liked him as an actor and he was an
interesting villain for John McClane
because he was a digital villain where
we have an analogue hero they had a
reason to not like each other besides oh
he has a gun and I have a gun I don't
like him it was actually a reason for
these people to clash the villain and
ir-2 was fine he wasn't remarkable but
he was okay it was a passable villain he
did his job well for what he needed to
be the villain in this movie is freakin
terrible he is just from normal movie
standards he's an awful villain from die
hard standards he's like a freakin
little ant nothing about the villain in
this movie is good in fact I can't spoil
anything about this movie but there are
multiple villains I'll just put it that
way and none of them
are good they're not interesting you
don't understand even what their
motivation is and to be honest the
entire plot behind these villains idea
for what they want to do does not make
any sense its convoluted to all hell and
it is just completely jumbled if someone
said to me Chris explain the plot of die
hard one I would say some terrorists
take over in LA kotomi Plaza because
they want the money inside it and John
McClane has to stop them
someone said explain the plot of die
hard to I would say some terrorists take
over an airport and John McClane has to
stop them someone said explain the plot
of die hard 3 I would say there's some
terrorists after some gold and John
McClane has to stop them and Samuel
Jackson is awesome if someone said
explain the plot of die hard for I would
say there's some techno terrorists after
some money and John McClane has to stop
them if someone told me to explain the
plot of this movie I'm going to actually
try to do it right now there there's a
bad guy there's a political prisoner
John McClane son is a spy who's trying
to protect him and John McClane then has
to go to Russia because his son gets in
trouble and then some stuff happens and
his daughter is there and then it it
gets weird and then there's a helicopter
and some uranium and I don't know look
I'm not even acting right now the plot
for this movie is absolute crap none of
it makes sense and I don't even
understand it I don't understand the
die-hard plot what world do I live in
right now another thing that is required
in a die hard movie is non-stop tension
not non-stop action non-stop tension
because remember what are some of the
best parts of the first few die hard
films the dialogue the tension between
characters it's fun to see John McClane
shoot step up and jump off a building
when it explodes and everything that's
awesome if it's directed well by good
old John McTiernan who made one and
three or Len Wiseman who made the fourth
one great looking movie really great
stunt work in that movie seriously great
stunt work in die hard 4 so John McClane
jumps on a plane and jumps off the jet
and then it explodes big deal i buy that
possibly in some world
might happen and the first one he jumps
off a building while connected to a fire
hose then crashes through a window
there's over-the-top stuff in all of
these movies but the reason you buy them
is because the way they're made because
the characters feel like humans they
feel like real people so you buy when
they go through the situations like yes
please live please live because you care
about them the way the film is made the
way it looks and the way it's written it
makes sense and so you buy the more
over-the-top elements but that non-stop
tension in which the hero is constantly
in trouble is always present in the
first four movies this movie has none of
that do cars fly everywhere do
explosions happen does John McClane
shoot some people yes that happens but
it is like a video game that's all it is
there's this big action chase scene
where they boasted oh it took us like
three months to film this scene it's
because basically a tank like truck just
plows through a whole bunch of cars and
they fly everywhere and John McClane
follows him it goes that's the scene I'm
not even kidding okay yeah some cars fly
everywhere but it looks like a Michael
Bay movie guys it's like a Michael Bay
movie the action in this movie is
tensionless if people were upset about
John McClane looking too much like a
superhero in the fourth film they are
going to blow their stack when you see
this movie his freaking truck flips like
10 times and he literally just gets out
and starts jogging without a scratch
nothing no blood nothing and he starts
running the CGI in this movie if anyone
complained about Max Payne the director
took absolutely none of that advice
there's all this over-the-top CGI with
John McClane flying through windows and
slow motion and matrix style action this
is one of the most disappointing movies
I have ever seen in my life and I'm
truly sorry to tell you guys that not
only it's just not die hard it just
sucks the only thing that even closely
resembles a previous die hard film is
the character of John McClane which
remains somewhat intact and I gotta say
the guy who plays his son Jai Courtney
he's not irritating he's not a terrible
sidekick and did a good job for what he
had to do and I liked their camaraderie
and there were moments in this movie
where I could be like man this could be
a good movie these characters are cool
this could be good
but it's not the plot makes no sense
terrible villain fake as all hell action
no tension
and it's short it's like 90 minutes long
this movie what all the tired movies are
over two hours it's like John Moore sat
down and went how do I piss off diehard
fans I'll make a die-hard movie and do
everything wrong I'm gonna give a good
day to die hard
a d-plus I'm so sorry guys it's just uh
thanks a lot for watching guys I'm
interested in seeing what you think of
the movie once you see it as always guys
if you like this review you can click
right here and get stuck menage